[Music]
test yes good I did my
usual guided aimless
research although this
is a listener funded
podcast I would like to announce our
sponsor for today which is air
fryers just you love your air fryer
right no brand and particular not a
particular brand of air fryer just rep
placing our former uh butt cleaner
sponsorship I feel like I'm about to
hear a pitch similar to when I pitched
you on the bedet like now it's like an
air fryer pitch you pitched me on the
bedet and now I can't live without it my
ass can't live without it but the air
fryer okay this is what totally sold me
on it I made steak in the air
fryer and it doesn't have exactly the
the charboiled uh Taste of a
barbecue but has the like carbonized
black edges on on the like far better
than an oven and I don't even know what
the not dry I would expect extreme
dryness you cook the steak in the oven I
don't have a barbecue where do you think
I live what do you mean pan fried bro
what are you talking about it's the best
that too no barbecue is I think the best
also I disagree with that 100% I think
barbecue steak is way overrated really
it's probably a little bit more
carcinogenic than the air fry because I
think I think that like that when you
have a flat surface and you pan fry and
you can base with butter like the juices
stay I think the barbecue is overrated
cuz like a lot of the juices end up
falling I think it has a much higher
risk of drying out the steak drying out
the surface and I just like a full sear
like I don't like grill marks I want the
whole surface of the steak to be seared
and have that beautiful myard reaction
but the grill M the grill marks are what
makes a steak a steak I mean I disagree
I've seen them in commercials
commercials are real life they should
sell steaks with the grill marks like
pre- burned onto them you know like the
subway chicken breasts have grill marks
pre-b burned onto them hyper hyperreal
but I like when the fat you know the fat
like Burns at the edges renders yeah
renders the air fryer does that the
gristle I like nibbling the gristle not
a steak fan so I do not have any strong
opinions throw it in a water bath there
you go do the I mean I have heard I have
heard good things about the air fryers
I've thought about it they're good for I
hear when you start like if you have a
big household they can suck because like
they don't hold that much food but like
yeah I mean I live alone so it' be
pretty sweet that's true so shout out to
our sponsors the patrons of course this
isn't a patron episode again is it no
it's not but shout out to them for
keeping us going and shout out to air
fryers for air fryer keeping your
keeping your tummy full and
satisfied first off we were a little bit
we're a little bit late to this but it's
Nazi day yay I mean we kind of we kind
of did this before one of our early
episodes but first off it's Canada news
you know we [__] love this we love
when we are in the international press
and we are it's our inferiority complex
as Canadians and this is we we have to
point it out this is such a perfect
Canadian story too a Canadian lib story
especially to lead into what we're going
to talk about I know it's a Confluence
of of a effect yeah very it's timely
Canadian politicians so eager to appear
on the right side of History aren't they
and then you stand up and cheer for a
guy who fought the Russians on the
southern Border in Poland during World
War II who else was there fighting
during World War II I wonder
H it's also weird that like you would
have in someone you would invite someone
who was fighting cuz like the Russians
like are were were the Allies we're part
of the Allies like yeah of course you
know you didn't condone the stalinist
regime or at least many didn't but it's
just funny that that they would bring
someone who like fought the Russians
it's just that's exactly what I'm saying
if you are fighting the Russians that
means you are on the opposite side but
the cold war propaganda was very
thorough it's yeah it's weird it's a
weird situation that they didn't do any
research on this guy before like to take
a few minutes and Google no just bring
in a vet that was it no this is what I'm
thinking you don't need to do any
research you just need to know who is
fighting the Russians that's exactly
that's what I'm saying it's just so
funny that they thought to themselves oh
yeah fighting the Russians in the
1940s early 1940s he Ukrainian veteran
and that's really all they saw they
didn't see the complexities behind that
situation and so I guess there's I guess
I guess there could have been a maneuver
wait but I I guess there could have been
a chance that he was a Ukrainian born
who had like
enlisted in the Access Army but wasn't a
member of the Nazi party right because
that's possible weren't there like
soldiers or were you by default just a
member of the Nazi party if you served
because I know there's a because there
is there was a distinction between like
the SS right the SS who were like
hardcore like Nazis right versus just
like a regular German Soldier right like
sure you could be drafted into the
vermar but I think the SS is almost
always voluntary and I don't know if
he's a member of the Nazi party because
he's Ukrainian but you certainly have to
be committed enough to volunteer for the
14th Waffen SS division so they bring
you they bring you to Germany he trained
in Munich and uh learn learn Nazi [__]
and he liked it guy's like in his '90s
'96 they didn't give him one standing
ovation but two because they're so lib
brained into thinking the ukrainians now
suddenly are this pure Bastion of
democracy and civilization against the
Russian Russian 2.0
hordes and did you see now they Poland
wants to extradite him I don't know if
you can put a 96y old on a plane and
hope that he comes out of the other side
but yeah it's complicated yeah that the
family moved to Canada in the 50s and
became activists or involved in the
Ukrainian Community because the
university in of Alberta which is in
Canada is returning the donations that
they've given to them to set up like a
Ukrainian studies program there they're
just it's like $30,000 they're returning
to the uh the children of this guy
they've ignored the complexities of of
like real world situations like this and
now everybody's jumping on their you
know virtue signaling Maneuvers that
politicians love to do institutions
swear by give back the money when when
you can easily go go to any foundation
and find donations from less than
reputable Shady sources but it's not not
they could easily just set up some
committee to look through them but they
don't well I'm glad you bring that up
because I wanted to ask the question is
what I did some research on by the way
we're going to get to haiger mhm another
our favorite Nazi uh yeah but he
probably is literally my favorite
Nazi not Schmid not not nah but Victor's
a a political scientist well I wouldn't
call myself that Schmidt's Concepts
aren't exactly something I don't
identify as I don't identify as a
political scientist political theorist
identify as an political theorist yeah
well do you do you go with Schmidt or
haiger oh uh haiger for sure if you if
one had to be purged from uh the liberal
University uh I would definitely Purge
Schmidt I don't know Schmidt's good too
like interesting on other stuff but he
seems to be more helpful politically
like specifically for political Theory
considering his uh his his ideas of
inspired people like a gamban I guess
and other many many others have Tak like
and and and stuff like that but I don't
know I just I think that hi is just a
way better philosopher and I just like
and I think the reasons why like haiger
have to do more with like being in time
and his his his phenomenological
ontology uh way more than I'm interested
in what he said about politics obviously
I mean I'm not that interested in what
and I don't really like and I never
liked even before it was clear I never
liked haider's later work it was too
mystical for me I hope we don't get
clipped for who's the best
Nazi before we get to before we get to
I'm the one who said he's literally my
favorite Nazi that's a good by a
thousand sound bites but why do they
keep
finding specifically Ukrainian Nazis in
Canada I think this happened a couple
years ago as well um during the whole
during the Great statue debates of 2019
or whatever it was oh yeah wasn't there
like a holocaust museum or no a museum
against communism or
something was that was but there's also
two
two monuments or like places for
monuments in Canada which are devoted to
this 14th Waffen SS division which they
renamed at the very end of the war so
they could get into Canada I guess but
it's I think they the new name is the
first Ukrainian national whatever but I
I needed to do some research on this to
find out um why this keeps coming up and
I found out that Canada is the second
largest Ukrainian diaspora of any
country in the world the first one is
Russia and our immigration policy I mean
this is extremely crude but our
immigration policy as a country has
generally been if you're
whsh and good at farming we got a place
for you we got a plot of land for you so
we got the ukrainians we got the menites
we got the Dutch they're all we we need
people to fill up the Prairies because
we got a lot of when was this this was
this was back in the uh this was a while
ago though right this was like 19th even
century and building the railway across
the Prairies and then there's no one
there because well I don't want to say
nobody cuz indigenous people but yeah
they wanted more Europeans we need the
whitish farmers to fill up the space but
the ukrainians kept doing something
bad which is they kept becoming
socialist and forming like Farmers
unions and farmers co-ops M so in I
can't remember when it was I think it
was like the 20s the
Ukrainian social or they formed a party
called the Ukrainian Social Democratic
Party of Canada and it was in like
Manitoba sasan so our prairies and they
got shut down and arrested by the
Canadian government because you know
communism but then the solution suddenly
revealed itself how do we control these
farmers who keep unionizing World War II
ended there's a bunch of uh I think they
were in Italy being held as prisoners of
War all these uh Waffen waffin SS guys
and
Britain this is so it's it's weird to
think of it in this way because Britain
was we're basically still a colony I
guess mostly and they're like we need to
offload these guys to go somewhere and
we want them to we want to put them
somewhere because they are
anti-communist they have anti-communist
bonafides because they fought for the SS
so Canada was like oh yeah we'll take
them they didn't do any real work into
checking their history checking their
background and there was plenty of
resources available from nurburg uh the
Soviets had plenty of information on
like who was who and who was in Poland
during this time but no uh our
government decided to do its own little
Nazi rat line
and we got we got about 2,000 of them of
them here and I got this from the
National Post which is a conservative a
conservative
rag I confirmed it elsewhere I confirmed
it elsewhere it's not just one that's
inter so it's like diluting the existing
Ukrainian Community with like uh vets
vets from that World War II and not just
any vets but Ukrainian Ultra
nationalists who had been indoctrinated
in Germany by Nazis and they always were
eager to surrender to the Western Allied
Forces because they know they'd get a
job somewhere instead of being just shot
on the spot by the by the Red
Army so then we have this problem of The
Monuments in Canada and yeah one of them
is in Oakville which is kind of down the
street from us and I didn't really think
much of it until I saw pictures but yeah
it's just just straight up what does it
say here in memory of combatants from
the first division of the
ud which is the first the first division
was they quickly renamed because they
didn't want to have the 14th Waffen SS
division so it's the same thing but they
quickly renamed themselves at the very
end of the war yeah I mean I guess I
guess the the Nazi question is still I
mean even though veterans if you were a
veteran of World War II you must like
this guy was born in 1925 I think so he
must couldn't have been wasn't more than
20 by the time the war ended so it would
have been in his late teens during
during the period in question but it's
still turned into this
huge Scandal yeah I mean just like every
time a new book comes out on haiger is
Nazism but but I was I was comparing
this also to uh our sort of national
self Reckoning with uh the residential
schools and with um you know the the the
slaveholding kind of roots in the
ongoing Fallout over slavery the same
sort of pattern right there's a big
Scandal some some huge thing emerges and
then there's a period of of
self-examination we can call it but it's
often involving statues or renaming
streets and buildings and institutions
and plenty of public discourse and and
and and polemics as well it's it's
falling into a pattern yeah one of
Victor's old schools had to be renamed
right was one of my my one of my old
schools too all right yes exactly yeah
he did his undergrad there tmu baby yeah
it was called Ryerson what did Ryerson
actually do was he an advocate Was An
Architect behind the the residential
schools I actually kind of um he so he
was so like with all these figures in
history I think he was like an advocate
for public education in Ontario but also
contributed to some of the stuff with
the residential schools um I don't
exactly know the details I mean I think
that you hear in the media kind of like
the worst portrayal and I've kind of
heard some other things in fact I think
there was there's actually a historian
at now called
tmu who was like kind of an expert on
the history of of Ryerson and he was
kind of trying to say that yeah he did
some stuff but like the way that it's
being portrayed is like not really and
there's like a bit of an argument about
it
but yeah so somehow involved in
residential schools with indigenous
peoples and he's a 19th century guy so
you can imagine what education meant
back then like largely a kind of moral
kind of getting the masses to be more
like the upper classes kind of situation
A civilizing it's not like education
today which is supposed to be you know
it is what it is today very different in
the 19th century we got to keep that
mind yeah it's not like he was
advocating to drop the tuition fees and
let lower class people into universities
that's not I don't think that was his
platform and then no but he was he
wanted to make sure that everyone had
access to public education sure sure
okay so like because back then like
public education wasn't really a thing
so he wanted to invent public education
as well I don't think he invented it but
it was like it was he was part of the
push to like to to to make it I mean I'm
not saying the guy is a saint I'm just
saying like uh like uh I think there was
like a like the original reason I guess
behind calling the University after
Ryerson was because he was seen as
someone who contributed to public
education in Ontario you know he also I
think did some stuff related to trying
to secularize education so I think he
was one of the people who was fighting
to kind of take the religion out of the
school at the time and make it just
secular education well I think his his
idea was that white people and
Indigenous people should not be educated
in the same schools that was his
position so he wanted a separate system
for non-whites and I'm assuming
non-white Rich males to be more specific
but he yeah so I
mean best in best intentions right I
don't know yeah yeah exactly exactly so
the question the overarching question
that we're dealing with with all of this
that we're bringing up right now trying
to be sensitive trying to be careful but
you have a a long history you have
problematic figures in that history how
do you deal with with it now that
history is over or how do you deal with
cause and effect from past to present
how do you negotiate the differences um
do you think there's a difference
between for example like Poland is
trying to extradite this guy because
being part of the 14th wa wafs he
certainly shot
poles they want extradite him this is
like a living person who did these
things who's now being called to account
for it is there a difference here
between the continuous statue debates
and maybe the hi higher debate because
haiger has been dead for 60 years or so
50 years uh is there is there like a
Reon Reckoning that's necessary who does
the Reckoning serve how do we put
morality our morality specifically into
history and I'll give you a minute
because
questions let me just go do another
dissertation
quickly I mean I kind of think that I
guess like the obvious way in which
history can serve some sort of moral
purpose is to like look back at things
and try to learn from what could be
contemporaneously perceived as
mistakes
um so I don't know that's like a really
kind of common sensical way of thinking
about it just sort of like yeah you
learn from your mistake or like you know
Society learns from its mistakes and you
can kind of make some some some sort of
some sort of moral
judgment based on that about today but I
think there can be an over fixation
on like also sort of trying to apply
modern standards to sort of Judge
history so like as opposed to just
learning from things and being like Oh
like that happened like we should we
should make sure that that doesn't
happen again versus this kind of
attitude of judging history
um from some kind of like moral
perspective and condemning past wrongs
maybe is a little bit different and I
sometimes feel it's I'm not really sure
what the purpose is of that though when
you say mistake it's like oh we did
another genocide oopsy daisies I mean
you think a mistake like something you
do in the moment not like something that
is protracted over many years like like
I tripped and fell and and Comm a
genocide for the next 5 years I don't
it's it's kind of a weird thing to call
a mistake or an accident yeah I mean all
I mean by mistake is just like looking
back at things that happen in history
that we don't want to repeat and that's
it's interesting that that morality is
very sort of backward looking like that
it's always like we have to assess
ourselves by looking backwards and it's
like moral decisions in the Moment Like
should I put this in the recycling bin
it's not so much but even then you're
think thinking about the past you're
comparing behaviors you're looking for
some kind of um I don't know relief
especially if you're if you're a victim
or related to a victim of something like
this then clearly you want some sense of
closure and that involves reliving these
events and and reexperiencing them and
trying to come to terms and and and and
assign I guess assigning responsibility
is the major thing right I was thinking
more about the way that you guys reacted
to my mistake comment and and I'm sort
of and I and I think I kind of want to
double down and say yeah it was a
mistake because I think that the three
of us here probably accept and I know
pills does the sort of ontology of like
thoughtless human beings going about
their their their business and like that
very little of what we do is like a
conscious decision right so
responsibility kind of a robust moral
responsibility
requires a
robust sense of
Freedom that that I don't think we have
and you know I also think about Hannah
Ren's um ikin in Jerusalem right where
like her whole observation is like this
guy's a [__] thoughtless idiot like
he's not like a he's not some kind of
Mastermind and I think I'm somewhat and
so and and of course like saying that
something is a mistake or like the
result of of a human failure to think or
something like that to use a Rens term
that's not to like absolve it of
responsibility it's actually like I
think a more maybe profound point that
like evil in this
nefarious like deliberate way where
there's like a plan and then it's like
let's like do this thing that we know is
evil doesn't really happen it's just
like there is there are energies and
people get caught up in like big social
movements and big social changes and
they just go with the flow and there's
like so many people I think that that
happened to they follow orders all this
[__] doesn't mean it's not like morally
aborn but that's what I mean by you look
back at it and you're like well we want
to make sure that that [__] doesn't
happen again that we don't get caught up
in something like that again might you
call it maybe something like the
banality of evil yeah exactly no I I I
just wanted to draw attention to the
mistake thing in terms of genocide
because this is very uh it's Politically
Incorrect to say that kind of thing
despite the fact to say what I just said
yeah it's politically incorrect because
like if you were there in Germany in
1933 you probably would have been a Nazi
statistically yeah you might have not
been but you probably would have been
well I probably wouldn't have been
welcome because my skin complexion isn't
quite white enough but you two for sure
especially up pills hey man my Paca was
there and he was in the resistance so
that makes me a good person
too but if you're in Germany true it is
it is much easier to be anti-nazi when
they come into your town and start
stealing all your [__] and sending it on
a train back to Germany I got British
and Norwegian background so I don't have
I don't think I have any of those kind
of skeletons in my closets but we'll see
never know something could pop up as it
seems to continuously do maybe you're an
ancient Norwegian Viking ancestors
colonized my ancestors and I need to
hold you to account for
this well let's move this discussion
forward into an endless cyclical morass
That Never Ends which is the haiger
debate in
2022 a third edition of the history of
being was released oh really and there's
continuous debate because heer's estate
usually run by his kids is uh pretty
interested in in sanitizing the more
anti-semitic remarks that he's made
haiger himself during his own lifetime
was pretty intent on you know
cultivating a certain image yeah and
they' they've had lines removed from
Publications redacted censored not only
that they lost an entire black notebook
and then mysteriously found it again
yeah and the question is not whether
haiger was a Nazi because he was or
whether haiger is anti-Semitic because
he was it's what do we do with that do
we burn his books I don't think anyone's
really saying that but then how do we
negotiate the history of what's
considered a great philosopher maybe the
greatest philosopher of the 20th century
with uh personal decisions can you
separate the art from the artist and all
that and uh We've read for today we've
read for
today Bard's response to this necros SPC
necrosed which is to look back on what
is dead fancy name and
bod is there a summary do you guys have
a summary of this it's just like we
can't care about this anymore because
we're hyperfocusing we're hyperfocusing
combing the text combing his diary
entries and his his uh conversations
with other people looking for any
indication of anti-Semitism but then his
general question is even if we found
that what would that accomplish what is
the purpose of that yeah it's it's
difficult to pin down
I mean the context is obvious right cuz
around what was it around
1989 1990 one of the famous books uh on
haiger and Nazism came
out um written by what was that guy's
name um I'll I'll I'll remember it later
Richard W um but no no no this wasn't
this wasn't wallen's book but wen's book
did come out actually like the beginning
of this year haiger in Ruins hence the
um hence the uh hence this episode I
guess in some ways but no and a a book
called haiger and Nazism written by a
french guy came out around 1990 so it
provoked responses from Richard Ry oh
Victor farus that was the name haiger AO
Nazism not yeah it provoked responses
from Ry and habas and and uh they tried
to get one out of dared dah and publish
it without his permission uh Wen did
actually and dared dah uh threatened a
lawsuit for that um because he wait can
you explain that story because Wen Wen
is the guy who is it the same Wen yes
it's is the guy who released Iger in
Ruins like last year or this year
actually I think it was the beginning of
this year but you told me Dara
threatened to sue him what what was that
about uh this was something something
that Martin Jay was saying in an
interview or a kind of Q&A with Richard
wolen is he was quoting this interview
that dared da gave on the on the same
subject of heiger and Nazism in maybe
1987 a couple years before this
collection was supposed to come out um
Wen wanted to republish this interview
basically he translated it and then he
wanted to publish it in a collection
and he he contacted the Publishers he
got the rights because I think he
contacted dared as American Publishers
and they signed over the rights but then
dareda saw the book and saw the
translation hated the translation hated
the book and tried to get his lawyer and
he ended up having the piece like um
retracted from publication in this
collection but anyway it was just they
tried to get der do to respond to this
book in a kind of weird lateral way but
yeah it provoked responses from all
these major thinkers anyway and and
bodard this piece is is in the wake of
that too uh so he's responding to I
don't know if you can call them
Revelations or just more of what we
already knew coming out in faris's book
and fun fact do you know do you know
where Richard Willen did his PhD uh
Toronto I think York social political
thought yeah
spt yeah but he he calls himself
I mean he says his moral intuitional
position is is liberal humanism so he
and and he's influenced by by the
Frankfurt School and his early work on
Benyamin and he described this project
on haiger as almost like going to the in
inverse side of
Benjamin uh Benjamin famously didn't
like haiger but yeah this this piece by
bodard is in the wake of that and then
more specifically yeah he's talking
about history right our strange
relationship with with history we have
these days which is where these moral
questions tend to keep coming up der
does answer to the question about
haider's
Nazism is quote who would have to
forgive haiger let's begin with the
hypothesis that hager's attitude was
infinitely guilty given this hypothesis
who would have the right to say I
forgive or I do not forgive I don't know
in any case not I my relation to this
has never been that of a judge or
someone who's in a rush to conclude a
book or a speech with haiger is guilty
and I do not forgive him it is too
difficult for me to do that and it's
kind of relevant I guess uh Dara is an
interpreter of haiger at the very least
and he's also Jewish for for whatever
that's worth but his response is like
I'm not going to be a part of this
instantiation of morality on the past
and what did he say uh you you you said
this to me Eric earlier about what he
didn't want to be involved why he didn't
want to be involved with this uh this
collection the reason that I quoted was
just that he didn't
like any of any of the book or any the
translation or anything that was
happening his his reasoning was just
like is that not my my right to to
protest in in this
situation I'm not sure the deeper
reasons for it his quotation is do I not
have the right to protest when a text of
mine is published without my
authorization in a bad translation in
what I think is a bad book some people
think seem to think that daro was also
kind of being a bit of a s for haiger I
don't know how I don't know how true
that is but well I mean so many people
during the well whatever after World War
II right have like forged their career
as haiger interpreters and a lot of
people on the left too so you have a lot
of career investments in haiger and so I
mean yeah that would put you in a very
sticky situation I've known some
professors who are big well into haiger
right and and they're constantly you
know harassed by these sorts of things
or people saying like you must be a Nazi
if you love studying haiger so much and
I mean that kind of [__] is is very you
know a little bit like workplace abusive
but I mean I can see the
career you know the entanglements that
these intellectuals get into right like
people right even like the French
existentialists were all hiigarans but
they were smuggling their ideas in in
the hosal back door or something like
that right and not mentioning haiger
even though haiger is like between the
lines everywhere when you read people
like sart and Pony when yeah but but
they can't talk about him they're
already kind of aware that they have to
use these ideas but position them in a
way that's like sort of not going to
create scandals for them and
and yeah all all the good that did well
when it comes to name dropping we could
just name drop forever it's like levanos
goder maruza yeah and some of them are
more critical than
others the point is again do you
separate the art from the artist do you
separate the writing from the person and
also do you separate the early haiger uh
being in time 1928 from late haiger
which is after he got banned from
teaching for a couple years and then
came back so how how much of uh gravity
does this or does his getting caught up
into Nazism which he tried to deny I
think it's demonstrably true that he was
pro-nazi
if you read his if you read the rector's
address is basically says blood and soil
and uh work will make you free which is
nuts but like at least my perspective
I'll bring my perspective in here this
yeah yeah I want to know that from being
in time which is
1926 or 7 to the the rectorship address
I kind of think that the directorship
address skews being in time in a
direction that he didn't mean it and you
can see how much political efficacy or
political changes happened during that
time because the Nazi party in 1928 had
like 3% of the vote as opposed to six
years later when they had what 40% of
the vote I don't know it's I mean it
seems also like the mythology of the
crowd and the mythology of the fascistic
state where you are a part of this
organic ho that has a spirit and the
spirit has a destiny I don't find any of
that in being in time and I've read it
quite thoroughly more than once so it
seems to me like he intentionally skewed
his earlier work so for the purposes of
career advancement or because his
beliefs change with the time because I
don't see in germ anything like the
German Spirit or the destiny of the
state while I do find criticisms of
things like doson and falling into a
herd and falling into a crowd and
neither do I I've heard some people kind
of nitpick certain passages and be like
well it could be read this way or like
when he mentions this but I've never
found it that convincing at the very
least I would just say that like there's
so much other stuff in being in time
that just I mean on the kind of more
direct question of just can you separate
the artist or the philosopher from their
work and I I tend to think think you can
for
me like I think that when I read stuff
I'm just like is this person making
points that I find convincing and are
like elucidating something that I can
you
know gain Insight from uh or like you
know is convincing in some way about
about the nature of reality or the the
nature of of of human existence or
something like that and I think that I
felt that being in time was for me was
one of the most influential books that
really helped me come to grips with
certain things about you know just being
being a human being in this weird world
that I felt like it was helpful gaining
a perspective on and I never really felt
that there was anything political the
first time I read it or the second time
I read it um nothing at least clearly
political I mean I remember actually the
the the main Insight that I got was just
how useful it was to sort of see the way
that like the rational actor theory of
like the human at the center of
political activity is just so wrong I
just f like there's so much good stuff
in being in time to show how that wasn't
true and yeah the influence on
phenomenology but yeah I mean I will say
that I loved being in time and I'm not
really thinking about the person that
much I mean I knew even even when I
first read being in time which was
before I think the black notebooks were
published like everyone kind of knew
that he was a Nazi like it's like oh
yeah like he has this history it wasn't
like a secret or anything it was just
like how much does it
matter um but his later stuff I did
personally find it wasn't so much that I
found it
politically repugnant but I just found
it like mystical in a weird way where I
was like H like I just either I just
like didn't understand it or I was like
okay there's like this kind of like
atavistic thing of like returning to
some pure purity of like that I just
didn't like it didn't appeal to me and I
never found it that interesting and
sometimes it it sounded almost even
though he was an anti- platonist I felt
like sometimes he would talk about like
being in this like or like
temporalization or something in this
kind of like weird platonic sense I yeah
what's not clear about the Gathering of
the foref F man you didn't you didn't
read being in time and then just
suddenly become a
Vish
not no definitely not and of course you
know I I don't know the the people who
make the arguments for not being able to
separate the the philosopher from the
philosophy I don't know what their
upshot of that is like like because I
think it it seems to rely on on what to
me sounds like almost a contamination
theory of like ideas that I've never
really found all that convincing that
it's like like the corruption of
Origins if the origin if it came from
this origin then like that must be
contaminated where like oh it might not
seem like you're like accepting some
kind of reactionary fascist
premises but you don't know because like
now that we know it's like he might have
like there might be a trojan horse in
your brain or something like probably
not a generous reproduction but
sometimes that's the sense I get because
it's just not obvious to me it's like
okay so you can't separate them so what
now like what's the danger like explain
it to me and I've never found the
arguments for the danger that convincing
it's like show me in his writings where
there's stuff that is like troubling and
I have read that stuff and I'm like I
agree like that stuff I don't like that
part of hi igger that that stuff like I
was in Ronald Beaner's uh in my first
year of the PHD and his seminar and we
and we talked about we went through a
lot of the passages in um in in in
heer's later work and I remember
actually putting my hand up and and
asking him uh you know what he thought
about being in time like I kind of was
like because because you know I I feel
like there's just so many useful
insights in there so many interesting
insights that just don't seem all that
political and at the time at least he
like he agreed with me he like I I I
understand where you're coming from like
I can see how that's not actually that
there's not so much uh and he said he
sort of felt the same way but I think he
I can't remember what he said I remember
feeling like he he he didn't disagree
with me um that he came on this podcast
and then we got I got a little heated
yeah you guys got heated I don't know if
he ever claimed that being in time was
like uh he was more about n back then it
was more about n when we were talking on
the podcast yeah and if I remember what
I was getting upset about it's because
he's saying these are fundamentally
reactionary right-wing views and I was
arguing of the interpreters of N and
haiger if you want to divide them into
something like right and left way more
of them are left yeah it's not just him
it's like I I I read the same thing in
Jackin it's like Alexander Dugan and
Steve Bannon read haiger so if you read
haiger you're like them yeah if this is
just a total failure or breakdown of
cause and effect or hermeneutic cause
and effect maybe that's a good enough
reason to read higar you can get some
hermen
understanding cu no one needs to read a
philosophy book to become a mystical
nationalist fascist exactly and if
reading could turn you into a mystical
nationalist fascist haiger is not even
the best at that if your goal is to your
goal's better than with Hegel anyway as
our friends at the Frankfurt School have
shown like haider's weird history of the
spiritual Destiny of the German people
nurturing the coming to being of being
that like what [__] heraclitis
discovered because they have similar
etymologies that's [__] stupid
shepher the being of beings that's your
political I'll believe it when I when I
hear the proud boys say chanting that
they are shepherding the being of beings
that's when it's
time look to all our proud boy listeners
if you're finding haiger too difficult I
have a book for you it's called the
philosophy of right and even you will be
able to understand it yeah I mean there
there's stuff you know there there are
certainly some ideas in there that
overlap I mean there's a reason why a
lot of radical left-wing academics
intellectuals were interested in hiig GP
because I think that there is stuff in
there that is compatible uh like you
know kind of like loss of community
rootlessness or whatever it's like there
like that stuff I think there's like a
little bit of overlap and maybe some
people would argue well that's where the
dangerous because if you get seduced by
this idea about like worrying about
rootlessness or something like that
you're going to maybe op stuff isn't too
far away drawing the strength from the
Black Forest land and things like that
exactly and and I think uh sometimes I
am even like slightly but not really
sympathetic to that because it's more
it's not that I'm sympathetic it's more
that I can kind of sometimes see where
the Horseshoe Theory comes in where I'm
just like oh like some of these radicals
just like accept the same thing as like
the right-wing r radicals about like
their concern for kind of being
anti-liberal at least right being like
against liberal maternity there's like a
kind of compatibility there but but but
it's certainly not I think this is
actually an important point to stick on
because I think everyone feels that
rootlessness and they want to find the
answer to it unfortunately haider's
response to the rootlessness feeling
that many left-wing academics have also
described is his is romanticism and
romanticism and fascism are always hand
in hand they're not the same but if you
have one there's always a risk of it of
one leading to the other if you have one
you have the well specifically
Romanticism specifically Romanticism
leading into fascism yeah so why don't
we shift here I don't know if I've heard
that you mean the the forest the soil
the Earth and he means he says I don't
mean I don't mean the Earth as a planet
I mean the Earth as its spiritual
Dimension as part of the forf well there
you even get some environmental
compatibility between right like because
I mean I mean the the the Essa
concerning technology is like I mean a
lot of environmentalists have taken that
essay up Environmental Studies academics
subcategory called Eco phenomenology a
lot lot of hoger influence in that right
because if you thinking about valuing
nature in and of itself or something
like that that might lead into uh yeah
some kind of
environmentalist philosophy yeah I've
heard that stuff haiger got caught up in
Nazi mythology of conspiracy theory on
the brain right he got he got he became
a he became an it's not Nazi philosophy
but he became a uh a kind of he got
swept up a little bit in that mythology
it seems yeah and lest you think we're
defending him he's also an anti-semite
demonstrably oh for but he's also anti
anti-christian
anti-bolshevik anti-am
he's anti- a lot of things he sees it
all he sees it all as
liberalism not expressing disapproval or
approval not trying to defend the guy no
he sees it all as this he sees it all as
this like technical rationality that's
closing being to us and then his respon
speak sorry what I mean the black
notebooks came out in 2014 right and
they they kind of give us insight into
one the depth of his commitment to
Nazism J antisemitism and anti-Semitism
all that yeah post
1933 gives his enduring commitment even
though he made little distinctions
between whatever vulgar Nazism and and
his sort of spiritual Nazism as he
proclaimed himself to be a spiritual
Nazi or something he makes those little
distinctions sometimes people grab on to
those but he's yeah it shows the depth
of his commitment and the length that
the high estate has gone to suppress
this information and and and the
opportunism of that and it's also kind
of revealed the careerism of academics
and and how that can motivate a defense
of somebody as much as some whatever
some disinterested seeking the truth
kind of can motivate somebody too I was
going to say on the question of
rootlessness I think it's interesting
that in the black not books I mean it's
not interesting it's actually just
like awful like the way he talks about
rootlessness and connects it to to jewry
he's just like says something like like
the jewry is an example of a rootless
people I guess because they like move
around or like they so they don't it's a
diasporic community it's a shot against
diasporas right and and and like a kind
of cosmopolitanism and then like
connection to to like all Marxism and
stuff and he's just like oh the jwy is
like a prime example of like a force
that is kind of advocating for
rootlessness somehow or contributing to
the rootlessness of society so he really
does connect his
anti-Semitism to like his philosophical
concern with rootlessness and his
objection to Communism is similar
because it doesn't acknowledge like
National Borders or the spirits of
people it says we have one global
conflict it is Bourgeois and proletar
and it's the same everywhere and he's
opposed to this because he's a romantic
fascist easy yeah and it's perhaps the
most refined anti-semitic conspiracy
theory writing you can find all right
because that's essentially what he's
working very adjacent to is this crazy
anti-semitic conspiracy theory that's
like still with us right in many ways
not so different turning to the bodard
piece of about this he's just tired of
this debate cuz like according to him
these
basic ideas or Notions of taking
responsibility or like a chain of
causation and the meaning of History we
don't have the meaning of History
anymore they're in the process of
Disappearing so histo historical events
like
Nazism or the war the great Wars or
colonialism they're not
now today mediated
by anything like a meaning of history
that we're all collectively engaged in
they're mediated by movies and TV and
podcasts so if you scrutinize these
facts about reality if you comb through
haider's Corpus find out all his
anti-semitic statements or anyone else
for that matter like coner
racist but these facts are are
meaningless and the form that historical
events
takes for us is one that's completely
unintelligible apart from that and we've
been studying for like five weeks now
myth and he kind of says straight up
this is putting everything in a mythical
Dimension we can't really engage with
the Nuance of History anymore because it
takes too much time so we entrust TV to
do that for us we watch Schindler's List
to learn about the horrors of the
Holocaust and we know that the Holocaust
is important but it's only important to
us through representation and then
what's the point of you know taking into
account this taking into account that
and then what do we do the the problem
is that no one has an answer into what
do we do so we're just continually
cycling this process that never ends of
how B how bad the past was how bad these
people how bad these people were and we
cannot we have no imagination beyond
that we have no vision of the future
yeah exactly yeah he calls to that end
he calls it the um the Mythic and media
Leed reconstruction of all of these
events and by all of these events he
means U trials and debates such as the
the haiger case but you could also
probably cite other people like Paul
Dean that was a big Scandal too right he
was a Nazi
journalist or
wrote very anti-semitic things in his
journalism do you think the land
acknowledgement is like a performative
gesture of exactly this
dilemma
absolutely it's a Gest it's a it's a
gesture that shows your own
powerlessness yeah yeah that's
interesting yeah it does it acknowledges
the situation and acknowledges that like
it can't be changed because history is
the way it is and that's kind of the
opposite point bodard is making here
it's like no history is is not what you
think it is in this way right and I I
tried to understand this loss of History
thing and then I remembered well this
was written in the early 90s which was
very soon after you know Francis
fukiyama end of History all and all that
kind of rhetoric was circulating right
because of the fall of the Berlin Wall
reunification of E and West Germany
defeat of Communism and so you have
everyone is out with their moral
trumpets announcing the victory of
liberalism and capitalism right so you
have that context as well this sort of
he's taking on this like end of history
and sort of in a kind of ironic way he's
taking up the end of history and saying
well history is either I mean he gives
it two polls even history is either
Frozen the way it is put in in a deep
freeze as as it seemed to be in the cold
war or history becomes just so fluid and
so you know postmodern I guess you could
say that there's nothing solid to grasp
on to there's no history being created
you live in a world where liberal values
and capitalist economic structure
dominate the whole planet and there's
nothing else to sort of compare that to
than you live in a world that really
doesn't have history but it's kind of
that's just kind of a moral argument
that fukiyama and others were making at
the time yeah kind of opportunistic way
of presenting their liberal humanism
yeah I was uh I was thinking about
something that happened in my
tutorial in terms of like just kind of
going back to the question that pills
was bringing up about okay so like we do
this we're kind of aware of these things
we're perpetually condemning history
but like exactly to what end and I mean
I think at the very beginning of this
podcast I sort of made the case that the
most reasonable one is just like oh yeah
we want to make sure we don't repeat
things that were really bad in the past
okay that's that's fine that seems like
a like
a that seems like a reasonable
motivation but the way that it's so
performatively taken up these days seems
like it's not really the function and um
and then it like so kind of It kind of
opens the door okay well like what other
ways could you respond to it right and
like one of them is like okay well we
have to like decontaminate ourselves
right and I think that's where like you
get to like these absurd conclusions and
in tutorial we were I was I'm doing a
tutorial on um law Justice and rights in
Canada and in the this week we were
talking about a famous case in Canadian
Juris Prudence about like when they
change the interpretation of the
Canadian Constitution for that so that
the word persons would also include
women because there was a time when it
would it was just it was just included
men landowning men and there's like a
case a Core case that went all the way
to London and uh you know back when
Canada was still had ties to the British
Empire but in any case there were these
five women Canadian women who were like
kind of uh instrumental to the push to
to to fight
this and we were talking about they're
called the famous five in Canada if you
look them up on Wikipedia the famous
five Canadian women and uh there's like
we were talking about it the
significance of it in tutorial and then
a student raises their hand and they're
just like oh well it's so interesting
that you know they that that that they
were fighting for women's right when
when meanwhile back in their home
province of Alberta they were
contributing to the genocide of
indigenous peoples or whatever and it's
like you know so they were somehow
involved in maybe residential schools I
actually I should have looked it up I
meant to look up exactly by the way I
don't doubt the student like I'm sure
that's true I have no but it's like but
in a way it's like what do you say to
that and I remember thinking and like my
response in the moment was just like
yeah that sucks and like unfortunately
like there's a lot of people that we
rever in history and when you look into
them you realize they're actually
scumbags like think about Gandhi think
about Martin Luther King Jr like he was
a philandering [__] and like Gandhi
was like an anti-semitic piece of [__]
like all you know it's just like all
these things and it's like where does
that go what does how does that serve us
what what's the purpose and I guess like
another way that I could have responded
and said like okay so like maybe should
we turn back the clock then and and be
like okay well let's get rid of the
person's decisions because the per
people who pushed for it were also
contributing to indigenous genocide and
we don't want that change to be
contaminated by the blood of indigenous
lives it's just like no obviously no one
would advocate for that so like what
what are we doing here I don't know it's
just like it's good to learn those
things you're right but it's like what
do you say to that I don't know and in
the same debate it's how how Nazi was
haiger what's underpinning that is like
who are the Nazis now so I mentioned
Dugan Bannon that's what people point to
but everyone is obsessed with their
future project their only future project
is who is the Nazi now is it Trump is it
the proud boys is it this group is it
that group because we have to orbit that
historical event forever and this is not
me saying this it's bodard but I agree
with him but Bard's point is we we had
an event of evil that's endlessly
reproduced through media through
conversations and the only purpose to
the Future then is to making sure that
that doesn't happen again there's no
imagination there's no progress there's
no vision for anything else because
we're so caught up in the gravity of
witnessing evil on the earth
definitively and everybody agrees from
right to left for whomever this was the
E some kind of liid this was the evil
some kind of liido yeah so this was the
this was the evil event and now we are
condemned because we have no future in
our our historical sense we're condemned
to just orbit that thing forever what I
was about to say what I was kind of
cutting you off there sorry it's just
like it just does feel like there's such
some sort of leidal situation going on
here with like this fixation on you know
even that student it's like it's just
what strikes me about it is like we're
talking about like a good like a good
thing that happened in Canadian
law and it's like what
is like I don't know it's it's not like
it's not like um I was you know being a
hyper nationalist about it I really
wasn't I was just like okay here's the
jurs and it's but it's almost like the
purpose of that is to be like well let's
not be happy about that because these
[__] women were like hated indigenous
people and it's just like I and you kind
of get that sense that there's some sort
of jeis sa happening on the part of the
person who's saying it the purpose of
this is to set yourself up as the moral
agent like despite any of your flaws
despite any of your personal moral
failings no I'm going to sit
above the entire scope of history and
say wrong wrong good but still wrong
wrong wrong wrong I I get to just sit
there in intellectual a mental Universe
of judgment where all of history is open
to me as a moral book and I get to to
decide to my own satisfaction that
everything that happened was bad yeah
totally agree but what's really
interesting about that that's not very
interesting in itself but what's very
interesting about that posture is that
it implies that history is over because
you can set it up as a little model you
can set it up as an object a little
representation subject to
judgment that no longer is in process
now it's now it's frozen like Eric said
but what that implies for bord is that
it just proves that there's nothing else
to do there is no future yeah and it's a
moral question that's that that's
essentially what it is it's about
morality it's about approval or
disapproval of somebody and their
behavior right then then that's what
we're free to do but but presumably
there's a history and there's historical
facts and realities and and and making a
claim like that you have to go back and
and and check on it you know like you
said do some research look into that I
guess somebody maybe who's of a more
like critical cast of mind and doesn't
look at legal decisions as as benevolent
and for the benefit of society but in
order to sort of perpetuate itself and
preserve its own you know function
rather than you know it can dress up its
decisions and rhetoric saying this will
be for the benefit of society but no
it's reacting to something in a very
calculating way it's not really you know
the law isn't about
morality right as as we all well
know what is legal is not what's moral
and what is illegal is not always what's
immoral right we it's very basic and
that would compromise the law if it were
just about morality so people get that
sense and then they ask those kinds of
questions about like well why was this
decision made why was this just can't
really float out that it was for the
betterment of society because that just
obscures the real questions
but I mean deciding whether haiger is is
is guilty or not is is is again a moral
question it has nothing to do with
anything except our own
self-satisfaction but once you're
sitting up in that place once you're
sitting up in that place as the moral
judge of History How Could You expiate
anything like how who would have to pay
for the atonement because there's no
there's no possibility to atone for the
atrocities of these genocides do you set
up a museum do you give land
acknowledgments of course that doesn't
atone for the crime so then you just do
you scour kant's Philosophy for every
time he was racist or haider's
Philosophy for every time he was
anti-semitic and then to what end do you
burn the books afterwards no it's like
we're still trying to gather all all the
information of these crimes find all the
evidence for these crimes as if we can
then take it to court and find a
punishment to fit the crime but the
thing is like bodard says there there is
no punishment that could fit the crime
so continually Gathering evidence is a
futile activity did you guys ever see
that old College Humor video about like
the moral hazards of everything or
something and they're they're all like
sitting they're all like talking about
oh what should we do today and then it's
like oh like why don't we go to like the
zoo and it's like no animal abuse and
it's like oh why don't we like do this
and like it just like it's kind of this
absurd and it's like well what if we
like go to the movies and it's like ah
you know like the the the studios are
really like you know they're they're
really like unequal and they're abusing
their employees and then it's just like
and it gets to the point they go through
that cycle and it gets to the point
where there it's just like well we could
just kill ourselves like why don't we
just put up like get a gun and shoot
ourselves in the end and then they're
like but the gun lobby it's like you
know we shouldn't be getting and it's
like they're just like and then they
ultimately conclude with just why why to
just sit in the basement and stare off
into space until and wait for the day to
end it's like yeah okay let's do that
man College Humor I always joke like
that it's a dated dated reference myself
I always say you know yeah if you really
want to hate something just research it
for 10 minutes and then like yeah you're
going to find horrible things in
everything to research yeah if you
really want to I don't know stop smoking
just research the tobacco industry like
it if if you're of that cast of Mind
anyway
which I am a little bit prone to Rabbit
holing so well I was thinking actually
of of bodard excoriating us for having
just a profound lack of imagination and
being able to do nothing about this so
we sit and just jiz forever I was
thinking though of the uh Tarantino
movies in this respect like um Django
and in glorious
bastards which are like historical re
rewrites because they they kill Hitler
obviously but they're truly postmodern
in the in in the bardian sense in that
they flagrantly deny history they don't
care about the meaning of History
they're just going to deny it outright
and then which at least at least this is
a new approach rather than this
performative meditating moralizing on
the continuous evil that everything is
so it's a it's a better reflection I
guess of something that attempts to do
something different than wallowing in
your basement wondering whether to shoot
yourself and then I remember the
reaction to I can't remember I think it
was in glorious bastards where they kill
Hitler in the end or they that actually
no I I think I'm thinking of a
completely different film but I think
the S similar discussion was had as to
as to why it was that Mar it was that
that Manson movie maybe where they oh
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood yeah like
the big discussion was like should he
have changed the ending like is is this
right like there was a huge discussion
about the fact that the ending was just
sort of fiction fictionalized history
like complet like alternative history or
whatever like Philip K dick that that
that series it's like alternative
history and so people were sort of upset
and unsure about that like can we just
do that are you allowed to do that like
is that is that immoral to just sort of
change the facts for an entertainment
experience like this and it it created a
a kind of a quandry for the critics it
seems and very yeah very interesting in
the context of this sort of discussion
of well yeah yeah we forget that media
is where we get our knowledge of the
world from right about about everything
like when was the first time you saw the
Mona Lisa probably not [__] in Paris
right like everything right like we get
it from and so if the media is going to
be blatantly doing this or at least
entertainment like movies then what does
that mean for our ability to I guess
moralize how can we
decide whether something was good or bad
I think that's right because it's a it's
a self-reflexive version of the same
thing that we do anyway which is to
rewrite history through media he puts it
this way the same goes for our society
as a whole which having failed to
generate any new history is doomed to
chew over the old one in order to prove
its own existence so yeah it's just com
repetition I kind of see see what he's
talking about here in terms of the
documentary boom because like since
these streaming platforms have come out
there's a documentary about everything
and there even documentaries about
people who are still like in the middle
of their career like Travis Scott or or
Taylor Swift which is an obsessive
neurotic need to generate history in
real time to to document history before
it's even happened but all this comes
down to for bodard the fact that we have
no future so unlike fukiyama who said
his history has ended meaning we had a
line and we got to the end Bard's case
is that we must annihilate history it's
our compulsion to annihilate any new
histories because we can't Envision
anything so we moralize the past as as
New Visions yeah even even said uh maybe
2000 will never happen because by then
history will be so [__] involuted all
right he calls it an asymptotic line
that like maybe doesn't reach its end
point and then maybe like turns back in
on itself
instead yeah yeah it's one of those
infinite
curbs yeah and it reminds me of the
repetition compulsion where we just have
to constantly sort of relive trauma
until I don't know some moment some
cathartic moment comes along where we
can sort of let go of it it's like very
kind of psychological take but I mean it
seems that's what happens as we relive
live these moments over and over I I was
thinking posing a question because I
think one of the things maybe we didn't
get on the table which does I think come
through in the Bood reading which is
that like the opposite of constantly
fixating on like the on being this judge
of History like there's also the other
side of that coin right which is like
those cringe Defenders of history or
whatever like people who want to like
and I guess it's just like worth putting
on the table like that that's like just
as bad if not worth
like it's just like being that he says
right at the beginning these are just
flip sides if you if you're defending H
or if you're combing through haider's
work trying to find the anti-semitic
terms or uh phrases both are the same
really what I hope that our audience
actually gets out of this is not us
saying none of this matters because
these I don't know they're they're
important it's good to be honest about
them and like see them but I want to
know how are they important because
acknowledging is not doing anything and
we we have we as a as a as an online
media culture have gotten to the point
where acknowledging is like taken in
itself as an act you didn't like the
videos during coid and where what was it
where all the celebrities were like I
take responsibility yeah was wasn't that
nice but I I was you know what I had in
mind though is like you know there was
and I think maybe to some extent still
is like a whole movement in in
conservative America to sort of
whitewash for example the history of the
Civil War right like they'll talk about
oh it's you know it was really about
states rights you know it wasn't about
slavery it's like that kind of [__] is
like so cringe too it's like it's so bad
like that stuff too but like I think
you're right two sides of the same coin
they've been doing that since
1915 yeah like the conserv and the
statues right putting taking down
statues what the conservative movement
was [__] doing putting up statues up
until like the 1990s of like of um of uh
what's his name uh General Lee right um
whatever his [__] name is like the
the confederate general like it's just
like putting him up and then and then
people are like now there's a push to
take them down and it was very clever of
the conservative movement because they
were putting them up and then they kind
of seem like they've been there for a
while but when you look into it they
actually put it up in like the 80s or
the 70s maybe even as late as the '90s
yeah was it the the daughters of the
Confederacy or someone something like
that exactly yeah there's sort of
different ways of being without history
now it seems and one of them is just to
completely submerge yourself in
Nostalgia and great gness and whatever
and the other T the other is is kind of
just progressivism and and and kind of
just looking to the Future
relentlessly and and just using the past
as a kind of lesson for how we should do
things next and neither view really gets
to the core or the Tarantino method
which is just to very obviously make it
up which is what the daughters of the
Confederacy did too you do that with in
glorious bastards too yeah that that was
good then when you sort of look at the
broader sweep of
history and you think well you know up
until the 18th century Society was was
generally hierarchical and static and
very sort of you know either modeled
after a cosmic order of things like the
great chain of being or it was looked at
as divinely sanctioned like the sort of
divine right of kings kinds of arguments
and then it then it began this shift
into a kind of well there is history and
change and so now how do we incorporate
this if if we can't have a full picture
of of society right now because things
are always in motion and there really is
no natural order at least nothing that
Society can reflect because we're
outside of that natural order if if
there is one then history becomes very
important in that context and so you
have you know historiography being very
very important going into the 19th
century and still for us today right
right you have you know Marx's
historical materialism for example
becomes a
very big method for for for critiquing
the current situation and and trying to
you know Inspire change and people to
take control and say you know we have
made history and we can make it
differently that those kinds of
arguments didn't become current until
yeah late 18 19th century and so we're
experiencing a kind of reversal of that
where we've had our history and and now
is something something different is
happening right this is what bodard
seems to be pointing out is that history
has become kind of polarized between
just completely Frozen the way it is and
in such motion that
nothing solid ever really emerges from
it and that's the side that seems to
have won with with capitalism and
liberalism is is this sort of
amorphous or what's what is he what does
he use yeah he's like the extreme
fluidity of of kind of Western
history versus the sort of static e
Eastern history of of the Cold War era
and now everything's been opened up to
this completely fluid history where
nothing really happens because it's just
so
changeable right so I mean that's the
broad sweep that's how I think of it as
history becoming important in the first
place and then now where are we today I
kind of look at like so history doesn't
matter in the sense that like we're not
going to come together over some
historical narrative and say like okay
this is where we are now this is where
we're all going collect itively of
course well this is why
haiger opted for
Nazism really was because it was going
to clear the
slate and clear out all this [__]
clear out democracy clear out
Christianity moralism Universal
principles yeah and then in making way
for the German Spirit to reach its
Destiny and if you if you ever hear
someone on the right say the word Destin
you you know who you're in the presence
of at that point yeah yeah all right
well unless there are any final thoughts
I think that's a place to end
it sounds good to me I'm pretty much out
of G acknowledging that we're never
going to end it uh because we can't yeah
so comb through whatever books you want
I do it too but comb through find the
evil point it out but pointing it out
has not really Advanced anything that's
what we're not we're not judging the
past we're figuring out what to do in
our situation even though these weird
things from the past kind of keep
haunting us the ghosts all right thank
you everyone this has been uh pill pod
140 the Nazi the Nazi I don't know what
to call it the Nazi episode
haiger haiger is a Nazi but we don't
care the haiger controversy Victor said
it not me
cut that out cut that out wait do you
actually want me to cut it out I'm very
interested in what else comes out of the
black notebooks to be honest but maybe
that's just a kind of a sadistic morbid
Fascination no I mean I mean final
thought haiger was clearly an
anti-semite and a Nazi there's not
really like any point in trying to I
mean and I never would have even before
the black notebooks came came out denied
that yeah that's I always I've always
been aware of it and it's always always
kind of put me off heiger or at least
diving into him as fully as people have
not that i' be going to be corrupted or
anything like that [__] it all right
goodness no that's the the tainting
theory anyway we are done yeah the the
contamination contamination there's like
there's a kernel of true evil in being
in time somewhere that might infect you
no one has ever become a Nazi from
Reading being in time you're either a
Nazi who's it or you're not a Nazi who's
yeah IDE you got write ideas don't
matter you got to write a new book you
you got to write something else being in
crime that's being leads to Crime all
right cheers everyone byebye bye next
week
[Music]
woo